ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا اذا مصادر عسكريه
اسرائيليه تقول ان اليوم هو اليوم الاقصى
على الجيش الاسرائيلي ونحن نتحدث عن اليوم
ال9 من هذه الحرب كيف يمكن تقييم
ذلك السي الحرب هذه الحرب هي من نوع جديد
يعني هناك جيش يعتبر نفسه من الجيل او حضر
لحرب من الجيل الخامس والاحدث تكنولوجيا
في العالم
مقابل امكانيات متواضعه مع استعمال
تكنولوجيا متقدمه مما توفر والدليل على
ذلك هذا المصنع للسلاح الذي يعتبر الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه انجاز واكتشفه هذا العامل
هو جزء اساسي لانه مقاربه المقاومه للقتال
تعتمد على تعقي تد الامور تعقيد المساحه
تعقيد المسافه امام العدو الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي اللعب على الوقت والمسافه او
المساحه وبالتالي انزال الاكثر اكثر اكبر
قدر ممكن من الخسائر في صفوف العدو هذا هو
الامر هو كل يوم بالنسبه له يوم عصيب
لماذا بعد 94 يوم اصبحنا باليوم ال 95 الي
لا تزال الصواريخ
تربط حرب في مدينه غزه مع الداخل
الاسرائيلي بدل العزل وخلق منطقه عازله طب
ما الفرق اذا خلقت منطقه عازله ولا تزال
الصواريخ تربط النزاع مع الداخل
الاسرائيلي مفارقه ان الصواريخ تنطلق من
قطاع غزه اليوم باتجاه تلبيب برشقه
صاروخيه بينما كان دانييل الجاري يعلن
انه جرى يعني الاست او تفكيك مخرطه كبيره
للصواريخ
لحركه حماس ايضا كيف وجت الرساله من وراء
ذلك السي المخرطه لا تعبر عن شيء
وحتى يعني النفق بعمق 30 متر لا يعبر عن
شيء انما هو يعتبره الاسرائيلي على انه
انجاز ولكنه انجاز بسيط من 500 م من
الانفاق وبالتالي هذا الامر على 30 متر
هذا الامر يوحي للجيش الاسرائيلي ما هي
التعقيدات القادمه في المرحله المقبله حول
الانفاق
لانه اسرائيل تخو اربعه انواع من الحرب
اليوم حرب المدن حرب الانفاق حرب تحرير
الرهائن
وبالتالي يعني نتحدث
عن المره هذه مزره يعني الجينوسايد كما
يقال ما يعني يعني تدمرين ثقافه وحضاره
وسكن وبالتالي تهجير وبالتالي 25 22 الف
شهيد حتى الان هذا يعتبر بالمعنى العام
مزره
مسؤولون اسرائيليون يتحدثون عن الانتقال
من مرحله العمليات المكثفه العمليات
العسكريه المكثفه الى العمليات العسكريه
الاقل حده والاكثر تركيزا هل يبدو لك ان
هذا الامر يحصل
عمليا يتحدثون عن المرحله الثالثه وا يف
جالنت هو من تحدث عنها بشكل
عام قب قليل دانييل هاري لنيويورك تا
اوكي ولكن نتحدث عن الشمال هو الاكثر
حضورا او جهوز حسب ما تعتبره اسرائيل
للمرحله الثالثه اليوم تم اطلاق الصواريخ
من هذه المرحله يعني عندما يتحدث
الاسرائيلي او جيش الاحتلال عن مرحله
جديده انما هو يخلق مشاكل جديده كل مرحله
لها شكل جديد منخفضه الحده قد تكون في
الشمال ولكنها لصالح المقاومه ستعمل لانها
تصبح اكثر
واكثر قدره على اعاده التنظيم اما في
الوسط وفي الجنوب خانيونس انها معركه
مرتفع الحده السي تسعه الويه بين الوسط
والجنوب تقاتل حاليا فكيف يتم يمكن الحديث
عن منخفضه الحده اشكرك العميد لياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من
بيروت